a lot of prisoners are used to try
substances that control feelings
however everything goes wrong when they
try the loved one
today on cinema recapped i'll show you a
thriller sci-fi movie called spider-head
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the film begins with a prison called
spider head in which we see that they
experiment with the inmates by applying
a substance on them which controls their
feelings we meet jeff
an inmate who like the others in that
prison agreed to be part of this
experiment on the condition that the
sentence be reduced jeff speaks to a
friend named lizzie and tells her that
that morning they experimented with a
new substance on him
then we see a flashback of jeff in which
we realize it in the past he had a car
accident with a friend because he was
drunk the next day we meet steve the
leader of the prison who is in charge of
the investigations he calls chef and
another inmate named heather the leader
puts these two inmates in a room and
then applies a new substance to them it
causes them to look attractive to each
other to the point that they end up
making love then the leader in his
assistant named the experiment the
substance of love although we see that
after the effect wears off jeff and the
girl end up very uncomfortable another
day the leader calls jeff to do the
experiment again but this time he puts
twice as much of the substance and also
an older woman and we see the substance
has the same effect because they also
end up making love
then we see that all the inmates have a
device attached to their back this
device is one that applies the
substances from the experiments to them
when it is activated by a cell phone
later
the leader sends for jeff and when he
arrives he realizes that in a room they
have the two women with whom he was
paired previously the leader tells him
that he's going to apply a very
aggressive substance to one of them and
that jeff has to choose which one
jeff replies that he cannot choose that
he prefers that it's not applied to any
of them but that if he had to decide for
one his choice would be random so the
leader tells him that what he is trying
to find out is if he has any preference
for one over the other or feels
something special for one of them due to
the experiment with the substance of
love jeff replies that he did feel
something for them but that feeling
vanished when the effect of the
substance wore off the leader ends that
experiment leaving the two girls alone
and we see a little more of jeff's
memories after the accident he managed
to save himself but his friend did not
that friday like every week they let
jeff make a call and he decides to call
his wife who apparently resents him
because of the accident since she
doesn't answer him he just leaves a
message on her voicemail apologizing for
the last time and promises not to bother
her again another day the leader calls
jeff again for another experiment and
this time he puts a man in as his
partner jeff gets very angry and refuses
to be supplied with the substance of
love with him and he also says that his
members still hurts from last time the
leader tells him not to worry because
that has nothing to do with the
substance of love and after a few
minutes of silence he lets them go
jeff suspects that they may have placed
one of the girls in a position to choose
between him and the other man just as
they did with him so he decides to go
ask the leader just to be sure
jeff learns that this is true and that
besides him there are many other people
who are also injected with the substance
of love he gets very angry and complains
to the leader saying that they're not
puppets for intimate entertainment the
leader replies that he's not doing it
for fun that he's doing it for the
greater good because if that substance
is perfected they could make many people
in the world fall in love jeff ends up
apologizing that night we see the leader
also has a device on his back and that
when he's alone in his room he supplies
himself with the substances to
experience their effects the next day
jeff talks to his friend lizzie and
tells her about the substance of love
they both agree that they're doing a lot
of strange experiments lately at that
moment we observe that jeff has feelings
for lizzy later the leader calls jeff
again and this time tells him that he's
going to give the aggressive substance
to heather the girl he was with before
and that he should tell him what it
feels like to see her in bad shape jeff
refuses to apply the substance to the
girl because he does not want to see her
suffer so leader tells him that he will
go talk to the committee to try and
cancel it although we see that he does
not speak to anyone and only pretends to
do so returning saying he couldn't
convince them
jeff seeing that he has no choice
decides to agree to participate
they apply the substance to the girl and
seeing her in poor condition jeff begins
to say that he feels guilty and that he
doesn't want to see her like this but
despite everything he doesn't feel
anything romantic for her then the
desperate girl hits the wall causing the
device to break down so when the leader
tries to lower her dose he realizes that
it doesn't work and the girl ends up
unliving herself because she couldn't
handle the desperation anymore the
leader and his assistant go quickly to
see the girl in the room and do not
realize that they leave the keys of the
drawer where the notes of the
experiments are jeff takes advantage of
this opportunity and decides to take out
the notebook and realizes that all the
substances and the experiments are made
to be sold later in the pharmaceutical
industry he tries to read some more but
he just sees that they're coming back so
he quickly puts everything away the next
day the leader takes lizzy for an
experiment and manages to make her
afraid of a stapler
thanks to a new substance designed to
create phobias
at the end of the experiment lizzie
decides to tell jeff how badly she felt
while they are speaking jeff tells her
about his accident and reveals that not
only did his friend die but also his
wife jeff tells her that's why he went
to jail so lizzy tries to calm him down
so he doesn't feel guilty and they end
up making love later the two start
talking about the experiments and we see
that the leader sees them through the
cameras and seeing them so close comes
up with the idea of using them both for
the experiment that night the leader
sends for jeff and tells him to give
lizzy the aggressive substance jeff
refuses to do that to his friend the
leader decides to postpone it until the
next day later jeff goes to his room and
after a while the leader's assistant
arrives to do maintenance to his device
jeff takes advantage of the fact that
the assistant is there alone with him to
confess that he saw the contents of the
notebook so he already knows that
there's no committee that is the leader
who sells the substances then jeff asks
the assistant why is working with the
leader if he already knows he's evil the
assistant replies that he didn't know
anything about his intentions before he
got there and that he just wanted to
help people so jeff tells him there's
still time to do the right thing
the next day the leader sends for jeff
to resume the experiment with lizzie and
we see that the assistant isn't there
jeff again refuses to hurt lizzie so the
leader gets desperate and decides to
tell him the reason why lizzie is in
jail hoping that jeff will stop
protecting her hearing that the leader
is going to confess her truth liza
decides instead to tell her story
herself she tells jeff that she forgot
her nine-month-old daughter in her car
for three hours which caused her to die
afterwards lizzie tells jeff that she
deserves to be punished for that so she
asks him to show her no mercy and do
what he has to do
when he hears this jeff decides to pick
up the phone to supply her with the
substance although we see that the one
who is actually affected is the leader
the leader begins to feel bad and jeff
explains that the assistant changed the
configuration of his device so that now
he can control it with that phone and
that the police are on their way
the leader hearing that his assistant
betrayed him tries to take the phone
away jeff immediately increases the
doses for the phobia and the aggression
substances causing the leader to throw
himself on the ground in despair jeff
lets him suffer for a moment and then
decides to lower his dose so he can
explain why he did all this
the leader tells him that he wanted to
create a substance that will force
people to obey any order then we
realized that all the substances that
the leader used were meant to obey
orders for example the order to make
something love someone else or the order
to be afraid of something and all this
was to finally gather into one substance
the leader explains that he wanted to
create the substance to make everyone
obey so that everyone would have to
behave as they should such as not
abandoning their children since he was
abandoned as a child
later the leader says that it doesn't
matter anymore because the substance has
already failed
and decides to confess to jeff that he
and lizzie have already been free of
conviction for a long time in a moment
of distraction the leader takes out a
knife and with it he manages to take
jeff's phone
immediately beginning to supply lizzie
with the aggression substance the leader
breaks the phone and then begins to
fight with jeff while lizzy frantically
moves around then jeff manages to defeat
the leader and immediately goes to save
lizzie just before lizzie hurts herself
in desperation the leader seeing that
jeff and lizzy want to escape decide to
announce with the loudspeakers of the
facilities that these two are trying to
escape and that if they do
all the prisoners will return to their
normal prisons with the full sentence
the prisoners try to stop the couple
because they don't want to go back to
jail while the leader manages to leave
the facility and go on a plane because
he doesn't want the police to catch him
jeff and lizzy fight the prisoners and
manage to escape from the facility then
just as they leave they see the leaders
plane leave and decide to take a boat
and leave as well we see the leader is
flying away very happily because he
thinks he's escaped but just at that
moment we see that his device was
damaged after the fight with jeff and it
begins to supply a substance that makes
the leader lose concentration until he
ends up crashing
jeff and lizzy see the plane crash and
finally leave on the boat saying that
there is no substance of love that it
has to be something natural between
human beings
the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue watching
more content like this thanks for
watching